Google cloud makes it easy to manage
scale and secure your Networks
in the networking and Google Cloud
course series learn how to implement
load balancing and content delivery and
optimize your network for performance
and costs hi I'm Barry a certified
trainer at Google and today I'm here to
teach you about the wide variety of
networking options and design patterns
on Google Cloud
in this series of courses you'll explore
and deploy Google Cloud networking
Technologies including VPC networks
subnets and firewalls you'll learn about
load balancing Cloud DNS Cloud CDN and
cloudnat this series of courses is
designed for Network engineers and
administrators who are either using or
planning to use Google cloud and any
other individuals who are interested in
software-defined networking Solutions in
the cloud before enrolling in this
series it's recommended that you
complete Google Cloud fundamentals core
infrastructure and the networking
fundamentals in Google Cloud quests
this series also requires you to have
prior understanding of the seven layer
OSI model
ipv4 addressing and prior experience
managing ipv4 routes
through a series of courses featuring
videos quizzes and Hands-On Labs you'll
gain the knowledge you need to configure
maintain and troubleshoot Network
components
you'll configure Google VPC Network
subnets and routers control
administrative access to VPC objects and
network access to endpoints in vpcs in
addition you'll learn to interconnect
networks among Google Cloud projects
interconnect networks among Google Cloud
VPC networks and on-premises are other
Cloud Networks configure traffic
management among load balancer back-end
services use cloud CDN to reduce latency
and save money
optimize Network span using network
tiers
configure private connection options to
provide access to external resources and
services from internal Networks
design networks to meet common customer
requirements
and configure monitoring and logging to
troubleshoot network problems ready
let's get started